[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous raconter une anecdote c'est
l'histoire du jeune fille qui apprend
qu'elle est se repositive à cette jeune
fille là on lui dit
tu n'auras pas de vie tu n'auras pas de
travail tu n'auras pas d'enfant
ta vie elle est foutue à cette jeune
fille là à qui on dit que ta vie n'a pas
de valeur parce que elle se repositive
ces jeunes filles là elle a cru un
instant qu'elle ne valait rien que sa
vie était terminée
mais
sept ans plus tard ces jeunes filles là
elle est devenue
mère de trois enfants mariés
elle prend la parole dans les médias
dans les à travers les réseaux sociaux
elle accompagne les personnes
séropositives à travers le monde
elle participe à des campagnes de
sensibilisation pour des grosses
organisations françaises
ces jeunes filles là c'est moi
j'ai appris ma séropositivité à l'âge de
22 ans 22 ans faut dire que on vit comme
n'importe quel jeu on est étudiant on a
des rêves plein la tête et après on
laisserait positifs c'est un choc c'est
un choc pour moi je me suis dit ah
seigneur tu peux tout me donner mais pas
ça je ne pouvais pas l'accepter c'était
trop dur je me suis dit je ne peux pas
vivre comme une personne séropositive
dans ce monde c'était impensable pour
moi
je dirais par la grâce de Dieu j'ai eu
le soutien de mes proches
qui sont aujourd'hui parmi nous
ils m'ont soutenu ma famille était là
pour moi mes amis mais je me sentais
seule
en ville certaines solitude que personne
ne peut comprendre on se dit
ils sont là c'est vrai mais ils ne
comprennent pas ma souffrance parce
qu'on me dit oh ça va aller tu vas
prendre les médicaments mais c'était pas
ça mon problème j'avais peur de l'avenir
qu'est-ce que j'allais devenir qui va
faire sa vie avec une femme séropositive
est-ce que je ne vais pas m'affaiblir
quel travail je vais avoir c'était les
questions que je me posais
mais dans la détresse vous savez
on rencontre des fois la meilleure
personne je dirais c'est la meilleure
rencontre j'ai rencontré réellement Dieu
je t'ai croyante mais bon c'est un peu
la chrétienne du dimanche et j'ai
rencontré Dieu
à ce moment où c'était le plus le plus
difficile pour moi où j'avais perdu
espoir il m'a dit Andrea ta vie elle est
pas terminée et tu verras ce que je
ferai de ta vie je n'y croyais pas
maintenant
j'ai fait une tentative de suicide parce
que je tends en dépression sont le
savoir malgré que je priais malgré le
soutien de mes proches j'ai fait une
tentative de suicide parce que je
rejetais qui j'étais
après cette tentative là je me suis dit
non faut que ça cesse
Andrea t'a dit elle est pas terminée il
faut que tu te lèves et je me suis levé
un jour je dis bon je veux sortir je
sais même pas pourquoi je voulais sortir
ce jour-là mais je dis que je veux
sortir
et dans ma sortie je rencontre un jeune
homme avec qui le courant est bien passé
et tout ça et qu'après mon numéro on a
échangé je me suis dit
il ne sait pas où il met les pieds ce
gars là donc voilà on se voilà on s'est
vu on s'est rencontré dans plusieurs
endroits au cinéma et tout ça pendant
deux semaines
je me suis dit c'est le moment de lui
dire la vérité je dis ah que je suis
séropositive c'est vrai que tu vas être
avec moi mais tu ne peux pas
il me regarde il me dit et alors il
rigole
peut-être qu'il va faire genre je
t'achète et puis après il va partir
bonjour et sur mes gardes quelques mois
on va des trois mois après notre
rencontre il me dit ah c'est toi là
c'est comment on fait pour garder une
femme j'ai dit on la donne
ok d'accord et 5 mois plus tard on a
fait notre mariage traditionnel
à Abidjan c'était la première fois c'est
vrai que la famille était là mais
c'était la première fois qu'une personne
me regarde simplement comme moi il y
avait pas de séropositivité il y avait
plus rien il y avait que l'amour il m'a
accepté dès le début sans même
réellement me connaître je dirais mais
grâce à l'amour il était là il était
présent pour moi il m'a soutenu parce
que c'était une chose de se dire j'aime
une femme et je l'achète et ça se
repositivité mais c'est une chose
de la soutenir aux yeux de tous
parce que ce qui va se passer c'est que
après notre mariage on a eu notre
première fille là il y a nos trois
filles qui sont là la première Elia la
deuxième Amalia il y a trois ans la
première à 6 ans et la dernière Sandra
qui a 21 mois et voici mon cher époux
monsieur messe Nicolas je pense
[Applaudissements]
et donc après
ma première fille ma deuxième fille je
me sentais encore quand je veux dire
triste je pleurais l'histoire je me
disais non rien pas toi tu ne peux pas
être séropositive parce que dans ma tête
une personne se repositive si une
personne qu'on rejette tu ne pourras
rien devenir dans sa vie
mais il y avait cette petite voix qui me
disait encore non Andrea ta vie elle est
pas fini et je l'ai pas fait que pour
toi tu dois témoigner tu dois parler au
monde et dit pourquoi
il est important de se protéger pourquoi
elle est importante d'accepter une
personne séropositive
dans cette voie là il a continué durant
des années dans ma tête je me suis dit
seigneur tu peux tout me demander mais
pas ça avant de prendre le micro moi
j'allais dire aux gens que je suis
séropositive qu'est-ce que tu fais de ma
réputation mais je suis foutue ma vie
elle est foutue et c'est ce que je me
disais
mais un jour comme quoi comme on dit
l'amour peut faire tout un jour je
décide de prendre la parole mon mari me
dit vas-y fonce moi je te soutiens je
dis ah et tes amis
et d'ici mes amis ne t'acceptent pas je
changerai d'amis je dis est ton travail
et d'ici je perds mon travail je
trouverai un autre
et en ce moment là je prends la décision
d'en parler il a fallu convaincre les
parents vous ne vous connaissez les
parents
ivoiriens
je dis mais
il faut que je témoigne c'est important
ce n'est pas pour moi c'est pour toutes
ces personnes qui souffrent et pour
toutes les personnes qui doivent éviter
de se faire contaminer donc finalement
les parents acceptés et j'ai pris la
parole le premier décembre 2020 sur les
réseaux sociaux je racontais mon
histoire et dites-vous que j'ai reçu
énormément d'amour mais que de l'amour
j'avais peur d'être jeté j'avais peur
qu'on se moque de moi mais ce n'était
pas ça il y avait des personnes qui
souffraient des proches de personnes se
repositives qui me disaient merci
d'avoir pris la parole et depuis lors
je milite je me lis contre la sérophobie
la symphonie on en parle pas c'est la
peur des personnes séropositives c'est
là toute la stigmatisation toutes les
discriminations envers les personnes se
repositives combien de personnes dans
cette salle
pour être en couple avec une personne
séropositive
ou même
vivre manger dans mes jambes manger de
la même assiette rester ami travailler
avec une personne séropositive
je ne sais pas mais il y a énormément de
personnes qui pourraient pas et c'est
dommage parce qu'aujourd'hui grâce à la
science aux avancées de la médecine une
personne se repositive sous traitement
et un détectable ne peut plus
transmettre le virus je ne sais pas si
c'est une information que vous avez mais
l'important elle est importante de
savoir que une personne se repositive ne
transmet pas le virus quand elle est
sous traitement c'est comme ça que j'ai
eu trois enfants sans transmettre le
virus à mes enfants ni à mon mari
la médecine a énormément évolué nous
avons une espérance de vie similaire à
une personne séro négative c'est à dire
que c'est pas dommageant positif tu vas
tomber malade tu vas mourir non quand tu
prends très traitement tu vis très bien
mais malgré cela nous sommes rejetés
nous vivons dans la peur l'angoisse je
vous dirai même des PDG des personnes
qui ont eu certaines influence si elles
sont séropositives on leur demande de
dire aux yeux de tous elles ne pourront
pas pourquoi pas peur de perdre leur
place de perdre leur confort de perdre
là où est-ce l'image duquel renvoie aux
autres mais ce n'est pas normal
aujourd'hui en 2023 une personne se
repositive vivent dans la peur
il y a eu cette parole qui qui m'a
libéré c'est-à-dire
le jour où j'ai parlé j'ai dit oui bien
sûr Andrea je suis se repositive et
alors
ce jour-là tout est il n'y avait plus de
chaîne il n'y avait plus de peur il n'y
avait plus de culpabilité il n'y avait
plus rien je me suis sentie libre
c'était une forme de guérison parce que
il a les médicaments c'est vrai mais le
plus dur c'est le mental et là je
pouvais aller où je voulais on me
regarde ah mais c'est pas la fille là
elle est trop positive mais je m'en fous
je dis c'est pas grave je suis qui je
suis et le VIH n'est pas mon identité
et finalement cette liberté c'est ce que
Dieu voulait pour moi ça dit quand il
m'a dit Andrea parle aux autres c'était
d'abord Andrea je veux te guérir à
l'intérieur de toi mais pour ça il faut
que tu parles tu as la parole est libère
quand j'ai parlé j'étais libre et
ensuite
j'ai aidé à libérer les autres qui
étaient enchaînés également par la peur
et là je me suis dit ça un combat qui
est plus grand que moi mais c'est le
plus beau des combats
aujourd'hui il y a mes parents dans la
salle il y a mes amis dans la salle qui
ont fait le déplacement pour moi
finalement ces personnes qui ont été
dans le soutien pour moi ont été
elle-même impactés libéré du regard des
autres elle peut assumer que je suis
leur amie je suis leur enfant je suis
leur nièce devant tout le monde et ça ça
s'applaudit parce que
ce n'est pas donné à tout parents
d'accepter que sa fille en Côte d'Ivoire
prenne la parole dans les médias pour
dire que oui je suis séropositive je
remercie vraiment mes parents car si
c'était pas d'accord j'aurais pas pu et
donc je leur dis merci d'avoir permis
que je vis ce rêve aujourd'hui
je sais pas où ils sont est-ce qu'il va
se lever
pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup aujourd'hui j'ai une vie
comme n'importe quelle personne je
voyage je mange
je sors je profite de mes enfants
dites vous aussi je n'avais pas dit que
je suis séropositive est-ce que vous
aurez deviné un instant non ce n'est pas
écrit sur le front et c'est pour ça que
j'aimerais donner ces conseils là à
toutes les personnes qui sont
normalement séronégatives et qui n'ont
pas fait leur test depuis longtemps
on essaieront on est souvent négatif
qu'on a fait son test sinon on ne sait
pas on ne connaît pas son statut c'est
important de faire son statut de faire
son test
chaque année mais on se rend compte que
c'est quand même difficile de se dire
chaque année je vais aller faire mon
test des fois tu te demandes ou même
c'est quoi je cherche même aller chez
monter chaque année mais il est
important de faire son test chaque année
à toutes les personnes sur haut
négatives
dire également qu'il y a plusieurs
moyens pour se protéger aujourd'hui à
part le préservatif il y a la prep qui
est un traitement préventif qui empêche
le virus de rentrer dans le sang dans
l'organisme et donc tu ne peux pas avoir
le VIH quand tu es sous près
la preuve elle est disponible en Côte
d'Ivoire
il faut aller voir le médecin sous
certaines conditions mais elle est
disponible en Côte d'Ivoire et c'est une
très bonne chose pour se protéger il y a
également le TPE qui a un traitement
post-exposition c'est à dire si on prend
un risque
on peut aller à l'hôpital et prendre un
traitement qui nous protège à 80% du VIH
c'est important d'avoir toutes ces
informations là pour mieux se protéger
j'aimerais dire également aux personnes
séronégatives
qui n'est pas nécessaire de nous
stigmatiser qu'il ne faut pas nous
stigmatiser il ne faut pas avoir peur de
nous est-ce que je fais peur est-ce que
je viens comme ça et vous vous dites que
bon je salue cette fille là elle va me
donner le VIH non
il ne faut pas nous stigmatiser il faut
avoir peur du virus mais il ne faut pas
avoir peur de nous car nous sommes comme
vous nous sommes vos enfants nous sommes
vos mamans vos collaborateurs il est
important de mettre un visage sur le VIH
aujourd'hui le VIH ça touche n'importe
qui
qu'on soit jeune qu'on soit dans la
trentaine la quarantaine qu'on soit même
âgée le VIH nous touche donc il est
vraiment important qu'on est stigmatise
pas une personne séropositive et aussi
aux parents c'est vrai tout on en parle
il ne faut pas prendre de grossesse pour
les filles les garçons à faire attention
de ne ramène pas la grossesse il est
important de parler du VIH à ses enfants
parce que le virus touche
majoritairement les yeux de 15
à 30 ans le virus touche majoritairement
ces jeunes et parmi ces tranches de
jeunes 70% sont des jeunes filles c'est
pour vous dire à quel point il est
important de protéger vos filles contre
ce virus là
et si j'ai un mot à fait passer à une
personne
séropositive qui est peut-être dans
cette salle ou qui regardera cette vidéo
c'est que le VIH ne te définit pas le
VIH n'est pas ton identité tu es toi
avec toutes tes facultés avec tout ce
que tu peux apporter à dans ce monde il
faut que tu te lèves il faut que tu
continues à vivre et à rêver on croit
qu'on ne peut plus rêver mais rien
n'étant aussi comme on dit à celui qui
croit tu pourras tout réaliser
aujourd'hui j'ai pris la parole à visage
découvert aucune porte ne m'a été fermée
au contraire toutes les portes se sont
ouvertes pourquoi parce que je m'assure
[Applaudissements]